Selena Gomez honors the late Christina  Grimmie with an emotional tribute on her  revival tour I don't really understand  how it was really haunted but I like to  dedicate a family is that she holds her  things so closely to her I think it's  not about a religion you talk about me  taking archives it's just that she had  faith the good for you singer was  performing in Miami on Saturday when she  was brought to tears while singing a  Hillsong worship cover called  Transfiguration  the entire crowd raised their phones and  lights in honor of The Voice alum who  was fatally shot during a meet-and-greet  after performing in Orlando Florida  Friday night later the crowd sang the  chorus with Selena